doha vous êtes ceci ma culture est bonne
vous êtes descendus
vous êtes descendus de votre toit et
vous êtes actuellement sur la place où
je racontez-nous ce qui se passe en ce
moment autour de vous tout à fait je
suis descendu de mon 17e étage perché
tout en haut dans le ciel
et maintenant on est au juste la voix la
pince rouge qui est l'entrée de la place
rouge qui est juste derrière moi et et
j'ai avec moi une charmante invités que
l'on connaît un puisque habitués de rt
france on a l'occasion de vous voilà de
vous appeler de vous demander un petit
peu vos analyses à karim les chefs de
l'ovcc au professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou
je suis ravi de vous rencontrer en chair
et en os mais aussi de même voilà donc
c'était très important pour nous de vous
recevoir aujourd'hui car vous connaissez
très bien la russie ça fait plus de
vingt ans que vous êtes installés ici et
alors le sentiment que moi j'ai eu en
arrivant à moscou il ya quelques jours
c'est un sentiment de fierté dans cette
dans ce pays avec tous ces drapeaux
rouges
le jour de la victoire la grande guerre
patriotique qu'est ce que cela
représente pour les russes en effet
ce qui marque énormément
c'est cette chute du passé mais dans le
bon sens du thème du terme parce qu'ils
font parfaitement qu'en fait l'avenir
d'un pays se construit dans la mesure
vous arrivez à intégrer toutes les faces
différentes de votre histoire nationale
et en ce sens là la grande guerre
patriotique des corails coûté la vie à
27 millions de soldats soviétiques c'est
quand même un chiffre qui montre
l'ampleur en fait de la chose et la
victoire est la victoire de tout un
peuple
donc ça fait partie de ces symboles
réunissent les pays et le 9 mai en
russie est un symbole justement puisque
neuf mais pas lui puisque comme on le
sait quand l'acte de capitulation de
de l'allemagne est entré en vigueur il
était déjà une heure du matin me
secourir
donc voilà l'on affiné et célébrer et a
été célébré sans interruption sauf au
début des années 90 ce qui montre aussi
la symbolique dans fighter de 7,2 cette
victoire puisque justement dans les
années 90 après la chute de l'union
soviétique où le pays était quand même
très affaibli politiquement où il y
avait une forte implication imprégnation
américaine ici étrangement le 9 mai
n'était plus célébrer ce retour marque
en fait aussi ce retour de la russie et
qui s'inscrit dans le temps et qui
continue donc c'est très très important
que quelles que soient les situations
cette fête célébrant c'est un véritable
devoir de mémoire en fait voilà que que
fait la russie qui est quelque chose de
très important se souvenir son passé
pour pouvoir peut-être se projeter vers
l'avenir se rappeler du sacrifice aussi
comme vous l'avez dit un de ces
personnes ces victimes ont dit que
toutes les familles soviétique puisque
l'union
l'union soviétique à l'époque voilà
c'était pas seulement la russie mais ont
perdu au moins un membre
ils ont été touchés vraiment en plein
coeur par cette guerre est ce que
finalement cette mémoire historique est
toujours vivante
c'est des morts et celui qui est
toujours vivante effectivement toutes
les familles en fête en russie et dans
tout l'espace un pas soviétique
aujourd'hui ont été touchés par par
cette guerre puisque c'était réellement
pourquoi n'at-elle pas simplement à
seconde guerre mondiale en russie et
dans l'espace possible mais cette guerre
patriotique parce que c'est vraiment la
gueule d'un peuple
du qui a soutenu son arme est donc il un
soulèvement patriotique et on en
retrouve cette mort vivante et le
régiment immortel a été pendant quelques
années le symbole justement de cette
nouvelle vente il est extrêmement
dommage que cette année il n'est pas
dessus
être réalisée par ce qui permet
d'entretenir ce lien entre les
générations de faire ce lien entre le
passé et l'avenir
et comme l'a rappelé le président
poutine dans son discours ce matin
d'ailleurs les dangers qui existaient à
l'époque commencent à resurgir
aujourd'hui et donc il est important de
tirer des leçons et lorsque l'on voit ce
régiment et mortels ces dernières années
qu'ils marchaient dans les rues de
moscou et dans d'autres villes de russie
et en europe
on comprenait l'ampleur aussi des
personnes qui ont été victimes de cette
guerre et ça peut faire aussi réfléchir
pour éviter que ça se reproduise
vous parliez de ces célébrations du 9
mai 45 que l'on commémore aujourd'hui le
jour de la victoire c'est d'ailleurs sur
la place rouge que les premiers soldats
ont battu le pavé
voilà on célébrant la défaite du
troisième reich commencent à évoluer au
fil du temps est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
voilà ces célébrations ce encore plus
importante plus grandiose plus
majestueuse que les années précédentes
par exemple est-ce que ça va crescendo
kg je pense pas que ça aille crescendo
que se différencient et c'est naturel je
pense qu'en matière d'émotions dans les
premières années au contraire l'émission
de lettres longtemps plus forte puisque
vous aviez les personnes qui ont vécu ça
nous va j'ai dit vous aviez leurs
enfants vous avez tout est à la fois si
tu veux cette énergie qui se dégageait
parce que s'il ya eu énormément ne sont
pas de mauvais énormément de personnes
qui ont été blessées les personnes qui
ont été handicapées mais indépendamment
de cela il y avait une énergie asseman
phénoménal qui se dégageait de cette
génération pour construire un pays et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a sorti
complètement l'union soviétique de la
guerre qui a permis de faire un bond en
avant seulement phénoménal quand on voit
les réalisations scientifiques
industriels
années 60 quand on sait comment le pays
a été détruit pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale s'est pas seulement que nomena
et c'est grâce à cette génération de
personnes qui ont fait la guerre
donc je pense simplement c'est différent
maintenant nous vivons
une configuration qui est plus
tranquille
nous sommes un petit peu apaisées
peut-être un petit peu trop et c'est
pour ça qu'il est d'autant plus
important de garder ses symboles de
garder ce lien de penser à ces personnes
qui ont défendu leur patrie pour
comprendre qu' il ya plein de façons
défendre sa patrie comme il ya plein de
façons car la guêpe uniquement avec les
temps qui on le voit aujourd'hui donc il
est important de préserver ses valeurs
de préserver sa culture tout en
s'ouvrant à celle des autres mais en
défendant aussi la sienne et je pense
que c'est cet équilibre qui essaye de
trouver la russie c'est à dire ne pas
s'enfermer
oui mais mettre en valeur ce qui fait
qu'elle n'ait la russie et l'effet du 9
mai et cette énergie que l'on trouve
lors de celle d'une afrique en fait
immortel ça contribue en fait justement
à cette force intérieure de la
population russe qui perpétue dans
d'autres conditions avec un contexte qui
est
téhéran qui à celles d'autres besoins ni
qui perpétue en fait ce combat des
générations d'un peuple qui aime son
pays et qui montrent effectivement
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire que
le jour de la victoire
là est encore plus important que la fête
nationale de son oui puisque le problème
celui de la fête nationale russe et qu'
il ya eu la période soviétique qui avait
établi son calendrier de fête pour des
rennais pour des raisons idéologiques
évidente a lâché 10 ans ce métier qu'il
a fallu réinventer un petit peu les
fêtes nationales
donc elles ne sont pas entrées si vous
voulez dans la culture nationale réelle
du pays
ce sont des fêtes officielles sont des
têtes institutionnels ne sont pas des
têtes populaire de la fumée et la fête
de la russie la paix du peuple aux bulls
ont en fait de la nation russe puisque
ça fait une
nation pour qu'un peuple dégâts nation
il a besoin se construisent s'unifier
autour des symboles et le 9 mai est
justement cette fête de la nation où
s'unissent en tout cas merci beaucoup et
bonne fête alors puisque voilà on se
félicite ici encore c'est ce jour de la
victoire
bonne fête à bousse diom pamiers voilà
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé je suis pas
arrivé d'apprendre quelques petits mots
doux facilement voilà